everyone needs a little pick-me-up a pat  on the back or the old high-five and  here's a little dose of you can do it  energy from someone we love  i believe it all starts with you and i  in the mirror i don't know how to make  collective change out there i don't know  what the policy is to help uh the world  uh get along better um  but i do  truly believe that if each one of us  look in the mirror and say you know what  i'm gonna be a little bit better today  i'm gonna be a little bit more fair  today i'm gonna take a little bit more  responsibility today to therefore get to  my freedom tomorrow  um if enough of us do that that's how we  make a collective change that's the  soldiers that i think we can all be  going forward so we can have a little  evolution  have fun doing it too break a sweat now  that was inspiring